joining us now with more reaction from
the Center for Immigration Studies mark
Krikorian and Fox News national security
strategist Sebastian Gork mark I want to
start with you first
what is this Caravan and who are these
people coming to our country they're a
group of thousand or so illegal
immigrants mostly from Honduras who have
been organized by a us-based group San
Diego based organization that basically
is an anti Borders group so what we're
seeing here is a kind of test or a
challenge of the administration's
willingness to enforce the law
and there are two things that I think
need to happen the administration needs
to make clear these people will not get
past the border or if they get in
they're not going to get into the
interior of the country if that requires
tent city to be set up on the border
whatever it is they have to be kept
where they are to send the message that
this is not going to work the other
thing and this is something Congress has
to do as it is now if you're an illegal
immigrant and walk up to our immigration
inspector at a border and say hi I want
to claim political asylum we have to
take that seriously and let you in while
we do that case instead we need the law
to change so that anyone who passes
through a country that has its own
Asylum system like Mexico doesn't even
get to apply they just say sorry
try Mexico that's where you should have
sought refuge because we're supposed to
look for it in the first country or not
being persecuted in so dr. Gorka this
has been framed as asylum seekers coming
to America because they feel like
they're being persecuted the group that
organized this is called people Without
Borders obviously a leftist progressive
group trying to make some kind of
political statement but can you give us
some perspective on how this isn't just
an immigration or illegal immigration
issue this is a broader more
comprehensive issue for the sovereignty
of the country absolutely
Katie absolutely so you know whether
it's crushing Isis whether its tariffs
on aluminum or steel or whether it's the
wall the Trump doctrine the make America
great again doctrine is built on the
plant
of national sovereignty and this is the
most obvious one I know this is gonna
make liberal minds explodes but guess
what no foreign national has a right to
come to America no one does
if we don't have borders who the word
America ceases to have meaning we now
know thanks to the leaked speech that
Hillary gave during the campaign that
her wish was to have a borderless
hemisphere meaning no borders from
Canada all the way down to Central and
South America in that case America
ceases to exist
but these people Hillary may have lost
but the the ideologues the iogic
activists haven't given up and this is a
direct threat to national security
because you can't have a porous border
and keep Americans safe
it doesn't matter matter whether these
people want to asylum that border is
there to protect us from drugs from
coyotes from illegal weapons and guess
what from terrorists as well Marc I want
to go back to the point that you brought
up about how the law in America is
actually working against us here if it's
an illegal alien is from Mexico or
Canada we can send them back but if
they're from Honduras El Salvador a
number of other countries we have to
then put them into our court system give
them a court date which the majority of
them do not show up to so how can
Congress act as the White House is
called on them to do today to change
this so we have more control of who
comes in and out of the country well I
mean the difficulty in sending illegal
immigrants back who aren't from Mexico
or Canada obviously mostly from Mexico
is not that many Canadians thinking
across the border is that with a Mexican
we just take them to the border the
Mexican authorities work with it you do
actually cooperate with us pretty well
and we just send them right back if it's
gonna be anyone beyond that Central
America or Africa Asia anything those
people need travel documents passports
they got to be flown there all of that
stuff and a lot of countries basically
drag their feet or simply refuse to take
people back this this this fact that
coyotes or drug cartels or even maybe
corrupt members of governments that
these migrants are passing through on
their way to the US
are being trained to say that they are
seeking asylum because they feel like
their lives are in danger what about
changes to the law like the trafficking
Victims Protection Act
obviously that law had good intentions
was it was implemented in 2008 but now
we're seeing it being abused over and
over again for example it was abused in
2014 during the child immigration crisis
then how can Congress work today to
actually make sure that people can't
just say that they're seeking asylum
when there's no background check for
that to prove that they're actually here
for that reason and unfortunately
there's no way to prove that really
because it's not as though somebody
persecuting you is going to send you an
affidavit saying yes I persecuted you
but that law you refer to the
trafficking Victims Protection Act is
for people who are minors and who are
trafficked now it's a jargon term but if
you're smuggled that means you're doing
it voluntarily
you've paid maybe your parents paid for
you to be smuggled traffic is some kind
of coercion or trickery you're being
used for sex slavery or something like
that the Obama administration used the
law that as you suggested is a
well-intentioned law but misused it and
said well these people are all being
trafficked and so we're gonna let them
all in
that points to a problem that Congress
can't see and fix every eventualities it
does sort of matter who implements the
law and if you have an administration
like the Obama administration they're
gonna take whatever law however it's
written and distort it and interpret it
any way they want yeah dr. Gorka
Congress doesn't seem to want to move on
anything when it comes to illegal
immigration criminal aliens what can the
president do in terms of his leverage
here with Mexico he threw out the idea
of NAFTA being a negotiating piece to
encourage Mexico to help us stop illegal
immigration into United States from the
southern border what do you think that
he's going to do moving forward to make
sure that people were reminded this was
a hot issue during the 2016 presidential
campaign and it's a big reason why he
won yeah so it's not that Congress isn't
doing anything half of them are actually
making it easier to undermine our
national sovereignty let's just look at
the recent huh Bob on the
census the Democrats were screaming blue
murder because we want to know if you're
here as a citizen or not and then they
shouted but that's going to lead to
voter suppression what does that mean
Katie whose whose votes are we going to
suppress if we ask you're a citizen or
not only one group of people illegal
aliens so you know half of Congress
wants to see these waves that Democrats
are losing the white vote in America the
middle class the working class vote they
think the Hispanic vote is the future so
they're actively undermining the
president and our national sovereignty
the president could do a lot of things
with his executive orders we've got to
stop the catch or release we've already
seen more than a 70 percent decrease in
illegal migration across the southern
border so you know allowing our Customs
and Border Patrol to do their job helps
a lot but it's not enough Marc isn't
this also a test for the Trump
administration and in terms of how they
react here because they know this group
of a thousand plus people is coming I
think the way that they react is
probably going to be watched by a number
of other people who are maybe planning
on pulling one of these political stunts
as well absolutely this is probably the
most important aspect of what we're
seeing with this Caravan is that it's a
test and an opportunity for the
administration are they going to react
the way say Angela Merkel did or the way
Jimmy Carter did years ago when Cubans
started being led out by Castro and
essentially result in a bring about a
kind of avalanche of illegal immigrants
or will the administration's draw the
line and send the message this is not
going to be tolerated you are not going
to get into the United States if you
pull this kind of stunt so it's gonna be
I hope they pass obviously I think they
probably will pass the test but it's an
important opportunity for them to send
the message that it's not just bluster
it's there's actually something behind
the bluster that we really are going to
enforce our borders
well dr. korkor last word to you but
it's very clear that the bottom line is
we have no idea who these people are
where they're coming from what their
history is and there are big questions
about the protection of Americans here
at home when thousands of people are
just walking over the border yeah Katie
look very simple the United States is a
house it has a front door you lock your
door when you go to sleep at night and
we have a right to control who comes
into our house that's what the president
is doing and I have a word for all these
nations that are complicit in
undermining our national sovereignty
Donald J Trump is not a president you
want to test all right with dr. Gorka
right kerkorian thank you so much thank
you